well Graham wetone is a policing
commentator who served for more than 30
years and can provide a bit of insight
into what's going on today Graham good
to see you um let's start by
um some surprise pictures I think
because when people heard that there was
going to be a surge of a reservoir you
thought it'd be concentrated on the
water but as Siobhan was pointing out
there quite of a loss of activity on
land yeah it seems to be focused on this
it's like outcropper land and as Siobhan
said huge area huge Reservoir but
they're focusing on a specific area and
you've got like a line of searches there
with their long stages literally turning
the soil over usually in the line and
they work across almost like a grid as
they move across the land on the right
hand side it's almost got a search
coordination team who looks to be
working towards either a map or a
diagram if one of the Searchers finds
something they'll stop the line will
stop they'll call those over we'll then
literally locate the whatever it is they
found and probably retrieve it but it's
being coordinated from the right hand
side by like a search that's called
Nation team and the search is in the
middle but again focusing on specific
area a fairly small area when you look
at the area itself of land and just on
the land at the moment other pictures of
what's been going on there today we did
see a boat on the water but it does
appear to be divers on board it doesn't
look to be I mean you see from this clip
the boat comes in it looks to be being
used to drop people off maybe it's
easier to get some people to this this
out proper Land by using the boat to get
some of their resources onto the land
itself
um maybe just being used as a bit of
security as well even just taking
pictures of the era just to map the area
before they go and search it so a number
of reasons how the boat can be used but
it doesn't look like it's been used uh
for underwater searches we're going in
close on the uh on the still the people
in the boat haven't got any dive going
at all I just got like a a life
preserver on and it's it's probably a
bit of an outer called and just looking
at the area it may well develop into a
certainly water but at the moment you'd
expect far more resources than just one
boat and two people yeah it's a water
search yeah it looks more like
practicalities it's about getting around
to the areas that need to be looked at
and what about tents we've seen some
tents erected what kind of tents are
they what do we think they're for yeah
they I mean initially when you look at
this you look at this from the the Drone
footage they look very much like crime
scene since we're used in the UK for me
they're not they're too far away if it
was a crime scene as such you'd have a
an outer called and an inner called you
Dev officer station there that almost
looks like a pool Slough I think it's
more likely to be a forward staging area
for maybe offices equipment some of the
kit to be searching maybe even some
forensic or exhibit bags Etc but it's a
fair way back to where the main briefing
area where the main reception area is so
just to save the office going backwards
and forwards all the time they probably
put a couple of tents there as a forward
staging area for them this is a final
question it's been 16 years since
Madeleine McGann disappeared what's the
likelihood of police finding anything if
something is there they look to be
working on some specific information as
we said because they're focusing on at
the moment this piece of land so without
knowing what the information is what it
is they're actually looking for what
they've been told they should be looking
for it's it's possible something could
still be in and it depends how busy that
area is used how much how much people
traffic there is how many people go down
in either drive past or walk past so
there's a potential there might be
something there but it depends again on
this basic information they're working
on okay Graham thank you the search set
to continue for the next couple of days
uh Graham wetton uh thank you for
talking us through what's been happening
so far today